there's a special way of treating
minerals and polymers in assembly Theory
where what in this in our life machine
we're looking at molecules we don't care
about polymers because they don't they
not Vol tell you can't hold them they're
not how how can you make if you can't
assern that they're identical then it's
very difficult for you to to to work out
if there undergone selection or they're
just a random mess same with some
minerals but we can come back to that so
basically what you do we got whole loads
of samples inorganic ones we got a load
of we got Scotch whiskey and also got
took arbag which is one of my favorite
whiskies which is very pey and another
whis do py mean is like um so the way
that on uh on um in Scotland in Isa
which is Little Island the the the the
the scotch the SC the whiskey is led to
mature in barrels and um the the it said
that the peak you know the the the
complex molecules in the Pete might find
their way through into the whiskey and
that's what gives it this intense brown
color and really complex flavor it's
literally molecular complexity that does
that and so you know vulka is the
complete opposite it's just pure right
the better the whiskey the higher the
assembly index the the higher the
assembly index the better the whiskey
that's what I mean I really love deep PT
Scottish whiskies near my house there is
a AOW one of the the lowand distilleries
called gleno still beautiful whiskey but
not as complex so for fun I C took some
Glen coin whiskey and our B and put them
into the mass back and measure the
assembly
index